I love when things melt in my mouth
we're here today at sullen means in
Koreatown and we're gonna try Korean
shaved ice
[Music]
I've never tried to read shaved-ice
before I've had like the spicier side of
Korean food but not the sweet side I've
never had shaved ice I've had a snow
cone I really don't know what to expect
yeah what it is I used to have the one
else little when I lived in Korea we are
ready to eat some damn shaved ice this
is not at all what I expected either
this is like a delicacy but this is
condensed milk you're supposed to spread
it on top of it this is the most magical
thing I've ever seen it looks like No it
reminds me of the Cheesecake oboes it's
so good you know that expression now
it's just melting in my mouth this is
just really good I'm trying to compare
it to something I don't think I can this
is so okay this is beautiful
it reminds me of like an Asian temple
this is like a masterpiece I'm scared to
shut up you know it's a good dessert we
have to take photos of it this is much
more earthy so I think red beans are
kind of a delicacy dessert in Asia I
just want to eat all the beans I've
never had ice that's this finely shaved
before it's an amazing food very healthy
tasting it's interesting as mom calm
[Music]
I really know already that I'm going to
love this it's so crafty I feel kind of
guilty about messing it up I don't want
to touch it but I also know when I touch
it it'll be the most magical moment of
my life this tastes like an American
version of Korean shaved ice it's so
creamy I think there's like little bits
of cream cheese in there so your
cheesecake cheesecake has made the cream
cheesecake bites inside of the ice so
you keep digging and you just keep on
bringing them go the ice is it's so fine
it's like biting into a cold cloud it
feels like snow it's so much softer than
American shaved ice
[Music]
oh we have a little Oh time to make me
fat uh okay over there this looks much
like cheese strudel and I love cheese
drew this is pretty it's like something
out of Zelda yeah I love green tea okay
this is just really satisfying this is
like the one that you want to eat
because it wakes your ass yeah it tastes
a lot like the green tea mochi oh my god
I can't wait I'm doing this all right
Cheers
it tastes like a sweet grilled cheese I
thought I'm gonna taste more like pizza
sugary it's like honey grilled cheese
that is so good it's like a sweet and
savory honey toast and this rice cake
has like a cheesy consistency on the
bottom it's like slightly toasted so
it's got like a little bit of resistant
I want to move in here yeah I never had
it before but I will have it again a lot
of different textures a lot of different
flavors that really played off well and
it just looked beautiful this place
actually brought back all my memories it
was so good I didn't know shaved ice
could be so spectacular every now and
then you need a nice cool refreshing
treat and I feel like this would be like
perfect I really think it's the perfect
date food there's enough for everyone
and it's beautiful to look at and it's
very romantic there's a pretty next door
called Teresa me they felt its
traditional Korean ice cream
[Music]